- [Voiceover] Alright, so we left off
with The Battle of Gettysburg,
from July 1st to 3rd, 1863.
And as I mentioned in the last video,
Gettysburg was a really significant battle
in the Civil War.
It was a real turning
point for the Civil War,
at which Lee brought
the forces of the South
up into the North for a
second attempt at an invasion,
and once again, was turned away by
the forces of Union General, George Meade.
Gettysburg was the most destructive
battle of the Civil War,
there were about 50,000 casualties,
and it, along with the victory
of The Siege of Vicksburg,
which followed the day after, on July 4th,
really start to signify
the beginning of the end
of the Confederacy's bid for independence.
Now, what you may not know
about The Battle of Gettysburg,
is that is was almost the end of the war,
in fact, Lee took his
army, trying to cross back
over the Potomac into the South,
and the Potomac was flooded so,
he and his army were pretty much pinned,
between this flooded river,
and the forces of Meade in the North.
Now Meade, if he had
attacked, probably could've
won the war right there and then,
and Lincoln was so angry
that Meade didn't attack,
he wrote him this really
nasty letter saying,
"I think you don't even
realize what you've done here
by letting Lee get away,
we could've ended the war
right now", but actually
Lincoln didn't send that letter,
he thought better of it, and instead
congratulated Meade on
his great victory and,
the boost of morale
that it gave the forces
of the United States, at Gettysburg.
So now I'd like to take
some time to talk about
The Gettysburg Address, which is arguably,
the most famous speech
in American History,
it's pretty up there.
And it's extremely short,
it's only 272 words.
Now Lincoln delivered
The Gettysburg Address,
on November 19th, 1863.
So it's about three
and a half months after
The Battle of Gettysburg.
I think The Gettysburg
Address is really interesting,
and all of the events surrounding it,
the circumstances surrounding it,
tell us a lot about
the culture and society
of the 19th Century,
the progress of the Civil War,
and also the way that things
are going to kind of be
wrapped up in the end of the Civil War.
What the ultimate message
of the war is going to be,
and what the blueprint
of reuniting the country
is going to look like.
So Gettysburg was this
tremendously destructive battle
with 50,000 casualties.
And remember that, after the battle,
Lee is kinda fleeing for
the life of his army.
And not too long after
that, Meade pursues him.
So the Armies make kind
of an incredible mess,
and then they take off,
leaving this tiny town of Gettysburg,
which has I think about 2,500 people,
to deal with 50,000 casualties.
So men who are dead, or wounded,
maybe missing in action somewhere.
And they really just don't
have the capacity for it,
so the Governor of Pennsylvania,
contracts out to create a cemetery.
And in this period of
three and a half months,
there are bodies literally
rotting on the ground,
so it's a bit of a hellscape,
the entire town of Gettysburg stinks,
they had to burn all the dead horses,
so it smells like burning
horses, and rotting human flesh.
It is not a happy place to be.
So the town of Gettysburg and
the State of Pennsylvania,
are very eager to get a
cemetery underway at Gettysburg.
And so they begin the process
of burying the bodies,
and re-burying the bodies,
trying to identify the various corpses
that are left on the fields.
And they ask this man, Edward Everett,
who is really the Preeminent
Orator of his day.
He was like the rock
concert of the 19th Century,
to come and give an Oration
on the Dedication of
the Gettysburg Cemetery.
And they say, "Everett, do
you think you can do this
on October 23rd?"
And Everett says, "No, I
definitely won't be ready
to have a script for an Oration by then,
so can you push it back to November 19th?"
So, it's actually Everett who decides,
what day The Gettysburg Address
is going to take place on.
Lincoln, by contrast,
was only invited maybe
a month or so before,
and he wasn't really considered
the important speaker
of the day, that was Everett.
But Lincoln knew, that he
wanted to make something
of his remarks at Gettysburg.
Now remember that, an election
year is coming up in 1864,
it's been a hard year,
Gettysburg is the first
major victory that the
United States forces
have had in a long time,
so he kinda wants to make sure that
he can set the tone of how Gettysburg
is going to be remembered,
and to reconfirm a sense of mission,
about the Civil War right,
when there's been such
a great loss of life,
and when you're standing around looking
at that loss of life,
it can be very easy to
get discouraged and say,
okay, maybe we should just end the war,
we should have peace now,
allow the South to secede and,
retain slavery, and
Lincoln wants to make sure
that people come away from
this Dedication at Gettysburg,
with a renewed sense of purpose,
in continuing to fight the Civil War.
Now there's a common misconception that,
Lincoln wrote The Gettysburg Address
on the back of an envelope
on the train to Gettysburg.
That is almost certainly not the case,
because Lincoln was a planner.
Remember that he was self-educated,
and he always took a lot of
time in anything that he wrote.
He wrote drafts and got revisions and,
wrote yet another draft.
He liked to be extremely
precise with his language,
and you can see that throughout
pretty much everything that he's written,
that he is an extremely
effective and eloquent writer.
And that wasn't just because he was
an extremely eloquent person, he was.
That's cuz he worked really hard at it.
So we're fairly certain,
that Lincoln spent some time drafting
The Gettysburg Address in The White House,
long before he left.
So, the day arrives, November 19th, 1863,
and Everett gets set up in a tent,
cuz he's the real headliner of the day.
Now Edward Everett was I think,
the undisputed champion of
giving speeches in his day.
He was an incredible speaker,
and everyone who was there,
actually agreed that,
Everett did an incredible job speaking,
he spoke for over two hours,
and if that sounds like
a really long time to us,
for the 19th Century that was
actually pretty appropriate.
That's what people
expected out of Oratory,
in the 19th Century.
They paid attention,
they were riveted by it.
It was like going to see a
movie or a concert today.
So people really wanted to hear
Everett talk for that long.
In fact, they were quite confused,
when Lincoln didn't talk for longer
then just a couple of minutes.
A lot of people even were reported to say,
"Was that it?"
So here in the center we have a picture
of the day at Gettysburg and,
we're pretty sure that this
is the only confirmed picture
of Lincoln at Gettysburg.
Now, he's kinda small here,
but I think this is a
really interesting picture,
cuz it gives you a sense of
what Lincoln's stature was at the time,
and also the people that
he surrounded himself with.
So, this is Lincoln here,
right here in the center,
not wearing a hat, looking down,
and then he's surrounded
by the important people
of his cabinet, so right here,
I'm pretty sure this is William Seward,
who was the Secretary of State,
and over here, these are
John Hay and John Nicolay
who were Lincoln's Personal Secretaries.
They went everywhere with him,
and this guy up here is
a little harder to see,
that is Edward Everett.
Now imagine what it would have been like,
to stand on this field,
in this growing cemetery
at Gettysburg, and
listen to Edward Everett,
and Abraham Lincoln talk about the meaning
of the battle around you.
Now remember, that it's
November, so it's been
three and a half months since the battle,
but The Battle of Gettysburg took place,
in the beginning of July,
and it was 90, 100 degrees outside,
so when Lee and Meade left Gettysburg,
they left 8,000 or more bodies,
rotting in the hot July sun.
And many of them had
been out there rotting,
for those three months so,
when you were standing on
this field at Gettysburg,
there would have literally
been human bones around you,
that you could see.
It probably would have still
smelled pretty terrible,
so you're really kind of in the thick of
the destruction of the Civil War,
and listening to these two men,
who are trying to make
meaning out of it for you,
so Everett gets up, and
he gives this fiery speech
for two hours, and he goes
through all of the details
of the battle and says,
"This is what happened
over on that hill, and
this is what happened
over on that hill", and he
tries to rev up the crowd
into kind of this patriotic fervor,
of not only appreciating the glory of
The Union Victory at Gettysburg, but also
renewing their hatred for their enemy,
and then Lincoln gets up to speak,
and he speaks for just a couple minutes,
and we'll talk more about that,
in the next video.